ces numéros aujourd'hui c'est gilles
verdez gilles verdez racontez nous et
c'est là qu'on va avoir besoin de votre
avis racontez nous l'histoire alors
cyril demain soir dans balances ton
poste avec votre équipe
il est prévu de faire un sujet sur les
coulisses du front national qui va
s'appuyer sur un livre qui fait beaucoup
de bruit c'est pas le tragique au front
national de sophie montel qui sera notre
invité voilà ça fait beaucoup de bruit
parce qu'elle a côtoyé jean marie le pen
pendant 30 ans emma et marine le pen
également exactement et pour ça l'équipe
de btp s'est posé une question
essentielle c'est de faire une interview
de jean marie le pen avec karim zéribi
eric naulleau et vous même afin d'avoir
que sa réaction sur le livre
alors on va voir ce qu'en pensent les
gens moi je vous dis alors sachez que
jean marie le pen voulait absolument que
et février que j'aille faire une
interview oui voila je dis je peux tu
être karim zéribi eric naulleau je
voulais vous demander votre avis qu'est
ce que vous en pensez
parce que ce livre va faire énormément
mais il est sûr ça parle de la période
jean marie le pen la période également
marine le pen
alors je vous dis je voulais vous
demander votre avion d'un premier
extrait voilà pour les livres sur le dit
par exemple il ya marine le pen n'est
pas la dernière à user d'une extrême
brutalité verbale et nous ne sommes pas
là dans le registre de la banale grande
gueule non je parle d'autre chose de
ceux du fait de se faire agresser par la
parole devenu poignard de se faire
hurler dessus et sont hâtives
d'humiliation au téléphone ou en face à
face avec ou sans témoin c'est un
extrait du livre et il ya un autre
extrait surprenant aussi il y en a plein
sans oublier cet assistant parlementaire
complètement délurée qui vous raconter
en riant et en mimant comment il avait
conçu s'est-elle députés dans les
chiottes du parlement européen il ya eu
ces soirées au sofitel de strasbourg ou
des types se retrouve à cinq ou six dans
la même chambre
ça fait partie du livre donc forcément
on a voulu aller interviewer jean marie
le pen là dessus qu'est ce que vous en
pensez bonne idée ou mauvaise idée
bien entendu ce sera une interview sans
concession va vraiment rentrer dedans on
va vouloir tout savoir on va vouloir
savoir ce qu'ils pensent également de sa
fille à quelques jours des élections
européennes
est ce que vous trouvez que c'est une
bonne idée ou pas vous bonne idée jean
michel mr bah bonne idée parce que je
comprends on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs ils sont en fonction de
ça qu'on va la faire ou pas je comprends
c'est vous qui la nation ce que
évidemment qu'il fallait interviewer
c'est lui qui m le principal fil rouge
de
ce livre scandale sa révélation ça
nourrit aussi oui et ça fait aussi bien
sûr mais lui les ja il est connu pour
être sans langue de bois
à tout lire sans fil surtout que
maintenant il a plus de responsabilités
au front national
donc évidemment que sa langue maintenant
vaut beaucoup plus cher qu'il ya
quelques temps où ils s'étaient sa
langue et est contrainte par des des
perspectives stratégiques la matin il
dit tout franchement si vous faites par
la bouillie ou faire des révélations
c'est sûr isabelle à moi je suis
entièrement d'accord et ce que dit et
jean-michel parce que la louve où les
trois vous êtes complémentaire vous vous
êtes en tête de gondole les deux autres
se laisse jamais faire lui en face est
malin et retors donc honnêtement ça
devrait être un vrai moment de
télévision et en plus un vrai moment se
disent les choses
remond mois pour moi c'est une mauvaise
idée
alors pas comme les camarades pas si
vous avez le droit pas pourquoi je vous
parle franchement pas ce que je vois je
pense que balanceront poste j'ai jamais
depuis septembre c'est à l'antenne et
elle a déjà fait parler autant d des
émissions qui sont en disant à l'antenne
qu'on n'a jamais entendu parler et puis
vous avez dit vous avez c'est lui qui
est venu vous contacter donc je pense
moi non là que je suis plus heures je
suis plus brillantes ça rapporte un
portier rallyes fia ici aujourd'hui et
on lui donne on lui donne la parole à
lui moi j'ai grandi avec lui j'ai grandi
avec ce tome la oumma en bas on me l'a
décrit comme comme le diable ces propos
j'en ai ras-le-bol j'en ai marre
pour moi c'est un vieillard il et qu'est
ce qu'on va lui donner la parole les
cerveaux talons là sur le nom est jonnie
fou j'en ai je pu le voir je veux plus
le voir
maintenant j'ai un soucis moi quand je
pars et quand les gens dont on parle
dans la rue avec les gens ils disent on
a essayé la droite on essaie la gauche
maintenant faudra bien un jour j'ai tué
sans parler du reste pas parler mais ça
notre sujet que des gens parce que c'est
un sujet sérieux si tu me coupe la
parole moi je vais vous avez la parole
moi j'ai moi je veux plutôt qu'on
s'occupe jeu plutôt qu'on s'occupe de ce
qui arrive
marine le pen marion maréchal le bel des
idées comme ça et décidé comme ménard cc
journal je veux voir plus c'est pas
celui-là tu veux voir
mais bon genre monsieur voilà là où tu
te trompes pardon vraiment je suis
d'accord avec toi sinon vsd et c'est pas
une mauvaise idée parce qu'on aime ou on
aime pas c'est pas la question la
question à mon sens c'est que c'est
c'est un animal politique un animal
culturel on aime on aime c'était mais
extrêmement sujet qui sait débattre et
ces gens là pour moi si on veut ne pas
trop les humaniser il faut les mettre
face dans les émissions politiques face
à des animaux volés s'il vous plaît je
vous le dis karim zéribi autre chose que
ça survient ce tournoi j'avais déjà
longtemps peuvent même si les gens
intelligents n'est pas encore pour le
moment
considérez les comme une émission
polémique qu'elle a lens ton post et le
forum pour s'adresser à toute la
paupière et oui tous les français louis
genre d'accord ni d'entendre parler à
cet endroit là de ce qui les importent
et je pense que justement ce qui n'est
pas intéressant c'est pas simplement sa
parole ce que lui va dire ce sont les
questions qui vont être posées lors de
certains qui n'ont pas l'habitude à
raison de 100 finalement un quart du
hameau raison qu'il va poser des
questions un peu présente à mon avis
d'un point les agents je téléphonais sûr
qu'il arrive si jean marie thérèse
jeunesse de tout individu justement ce
n'est pas une émission comme les autres
et que justement il sera peut-être
peut-être je dis bien
désarçonné par le fait qu'il aura en
face de lui des interlocuteurs qu'il n'a
pas l'habitude de côtoyer cris sont pas
formatés je peux terminer un journal
dans ses politiques
il a une façon de fonctionner que
connaît parfaitement bien une jean marie
le pen marine le pen et marion
maréchal-le pen
ils savent comment ça fonctionne parce
qu'ils sont du sérail or cyril mais pas
du sérail
donc je pense que cyril peu le
désarçonner et cyril lui-même aura
besoin d'être épaulés par des gens qui
eux en partie du sérail comme karim
zéribi et comme eric naulleau qui lui
est érodée à faire des interviews
politiques donc je pense que c'est lui
huit personnalités totalement
différentes qui vont apporter des choses
à la fois bancal à la syrie etc
ça peut être ça peut être si la question
est est-ce qu'on doit l'entendre ou pas
pour moi la réponse est oui dans une
émission comme balances ton post qui est
une émission de débat où vous
donner la parole à tout le monde vous me
l'avez prouvé depuis le début si on
continue dans cette logique là je ne
vois pas pourquoi jean marie le pen qui
est acculé quand même dans ce bouquin ne
pourrait pas répondre
je suis désolé on pense qu'on va pour
uniquement par évidemment c'est pas mon
truc c'est on doit lui donner la parole
though i moi je suis entièrement
d'accord tu fais une grosse erreur
mathieu quand tu dis les médias c'est
n'est pas reconnue par le média qu'est
ce qu'on s'en fout elle est reconnue par
les téléspectateurs et a priori on fait
une émission bas la première marche ans
quand elle a reçu le colonel rossi la
démission de la tête de bastos et eric
revel ses amis c'était patron de lci est
vrai karim zéribi c'est un énorme
journaliste eric naulleau j'ai eu désolé
ou codées son cv si mme kelly a été
dédouané haussé sa blessure à sa
démission
c'est une bonne journaliste haussier
sablé mais juste suivi ce qui s'est
passé depuis 20 ans que le front
national
à chaque fois qu'il était face à des
gens justement qu'est pas les
journalistes politiques établies à
chaque fois et s'est planté première
fois c'était avec d'ailleurs avec tapis
il s'est fait massacrer est le pire
ennemi de le pen en télévision s'est
lui-même donc une aura des gens nombreux
fans de lui et puis le rideau qui
donneront la parole est plus adroit sort
est un moyen de vendre des
téléspectateurs c'est eux qui vont avoir
le meilleur goût
ce soir vous en tant que t1 ben voilà en
mauvais parce qu'on est là on va pour
être en contradicteur pour savoir
vraiment ce s'est passé
moi j'ai envie de savoir aujourd'hui de
sa fille il ya les élections européennes
qui arrive dans quelques semaines j'ai
envie de savoir ce qu'ils pensent aussi
de marion maréchal-le pen qui est sa
vraie c'est qu'ils sont vrais savait
mais a dit hier je suis désolé moi j'ai
envie de le savoir questions des gens
apparemment ou envie de savoir aussi
donc je vous le dis demain j'irai donc
interviewé jean marie le pen puisque à
67%
vous voulez que j'y aille j'irai donc
avec karim zéribi eric naulleau
l'interviewer sans concession